D
RIFLED THROUGH HER AND HER SON
BARON'S.
HERE THE REACTION, WISCONSIN
SENATOR RON JOHNSON IS WITH US.
SENATOR.
WE HAVE CONFIRMED ON THIS SHOW
THAT THERE ARE OVER 20 FBI
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
YOU KNOW OF MANY OF THEM.
WE NOW KNOW THE FBI HAS BEEN
POLITICIZED.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE DOJ HAS BEEN
WEAPONIZED.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS THERE ARE
REPORTS OUT THERE THESE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS BELIEVE THAT
DIRECTOR WRAY HAS LOST CONTROL
OF THE BUREAU.
ARE YOU HEARING THAT?
>> NOT SPECIFICALLY THAT.
I FIRST HAVE TO COMMENT ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN MEMPHIS.
IT IS HORRIFIC.
MY THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS GOING TO
FOLKS THEY ARE.
YOU MENTIONED THE TWO-TIER
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
I'M CALLING IT THREE-TIERED.
YOU HAVE THE ONE SYSTEM THAT
TREATS HILLARY CLINTON AND
HUNTER BIDEN WITH KID GLOVES.
YOU HAVE THE ONE FOR MOST OTHER
AMERICANS.
THEN YOU HAVE THE WEAPONIZATION
OF NOT ONLY THE FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT, FEDERAL AGENCIES
LIKE THE IRS, LIKE OSHA.
THEY COME AFTER THE DEMOCRATS'
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THAT'S VERY CORROSIVE TO OUR
DEMOCRACY.
WE ARE SEEING IT PLAY OUT TIME
AND TIME AGAIN.
WE ARE HEARING FROM
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
GOD BLESS THEM FOR COMING
FORWARD.
PEOPLE WITH INTEGRITY AND THE
AGENCIES THAT WANT THEIR
AGENCIES RESTORED.
TO HAVE THE CREDIBILITY,
INTEGRITY.
THEY ARE GOING FORWARD AND THEY
ARE STARTING TO TALK ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING
TO RESTORE INTEGRITY.
UNDERSTAND THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: THEY GOT A REMINDER
FROM THE ATTORNEY GENERAL THEY
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO TALK TO
ELECTED OFFICIALS, SENATORS,
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN.
IS THAT YOUR UNDERSTANDING?
IT SOUNDS AN AWFUL LOT LIKE
INTIMIDATION TO ME.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL COULD ISSUE
THAT.
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAVE THE RIGHT TO
COME FORWARD TO CONGRESS AND BE
AFFORDED WHISTLE-BLOWER
PROTECTION.
I AM CALLING ON PEOPLE NOT JUST
IN THE FBI, NOT JUST THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IF YOU ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING IN YOUR AGENCY, THE
POLITICIZATION OF IT.
BEING WEAPONIZED AGAINST
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
COME TALK TO US.
WE WILL AFFORD YOU THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER PROTECTION.
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GOING
TO RESTORE CONFIDENCE IN THESE
AGENCIES.
WE NEED TO EXPOSE THE TRUTH AND
THAT'S PRETTY MUCH MY MISSION.
>> Sean: SENATOR, I HAVE BEEN
WATCHING YOUR CAMPAIGN AND
ACCORDING TO SOME ESTIMATES
THERE ABOUT $50 MILLION ALREADY
SPENT ON NEGATIVE ADS ATTACKING
YOU.
A LOT OF THAT MONEY COMING FROM
OUTSIDE OF WISCONSIN.
ONE OF THE BIG LIES THEY ARE
TELLING US THAT YOU WANT TO CUT
BACK ON SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS
AND MEDICARE BENEFITS.
IT'S NOT TRUE.
I WANT TO GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO
RESPOND AND WHAT DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT YOUR OPPONENT, BARNS, THAT
AMERICA WOULD NEED TO KNOW
WHETHER THE PEOPLE OF WISCONSIN
NEED TO KNOW?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THAT'S PROBABLY
THE BIGGEST OF MANY LIVES.
THINK OF IT FOR A MOMENT.
WHAT ELECTED OFFICIAL WOULD EVER
PROPOSE CUTTING OR ENDING
SOCIAL SECURITY.
IT'S ABSURD ON ITS FACE.
I WANT TO SAVE SOCIAL SECURITY.
WHAT WISCONSINITES NEEDS TO KNOW
ABOUT MANDELA BARNES IS HE'S A
RADICAL LEFTIST.
HE'S A GUY WHO THINKS THE
FOUNDING OF AMERICA WAS AWFUL.
HE THINKS NATIONAL PARKS ARE
RACIST.
WHAT'S RACIST ABOUT
OLD FAITHFUL?
HE SUPPORTS ALL OF THE RADICAL
POLICIES OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND IS CAUSING SO
MUCH PAIN FOR WISCONSINITES.
40 YEAR HIGH INFLATION, RISING
GAS PRICES, CRIME, THE OPEN
BORDER FLOODING OUR STATES WITH
DEADLY DRUGS AND KILLING OUR
SUBSTANCE.
HE SUPPORTS ALL THOSE THINGS BUT
HE IS IN HIDING, SEAN.
HE WILL NOT ANSWER QUESTIONS
FROM THE PRESS.
HE WANTS TO PULL THE WOOL OVER
WISCONSINITES' EYES WHILE HE'S
LYING, SNEERING, LYING ABOUT ME,
SMEARING ABOUT ME, ASSASSINATING
MY CHARACTER.
THAT'S ALL HE HAS.
HE CAN'T DEFEND DEMOCRAT
POLICIES AND HE CAN'T DEFEND HIS
PAST POSITIONS ON THESE ISSUES.
>> Sean: SAME ISSUE GOING ON
IN STATES LIKE GEORGIA.
HER WILL TALK TO HERSCHEL
WALKER.
STATES LIKE PENNSYLVANIA WITH
DR. ROSS.
THIS GUY, FETTERMAN, HE'S
CAMPAIGN FOR A WHOPPING
20 MINUTES THE ENTIRE GENERAL
ELECTI